-Welcome back.
You look fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
Number-one movie.
-It's not a big deal.
It's all me.
It's been -- it's all me.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh, wow.
I have to --
since the last time I saw you,
you have a baby boy now.
Congratulations.
-I had a boy, yes.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And thank you
for the music sting
for me announcing
that I have a boy.
I really appreciate that.
♪♪
-That's the sting you get
for thanking them
for the announcement.
-Well, thank you
for the double sting, guys.
I really appreciate it.
♪♪
Hey!
-Oh, my God!
This never happens.
The double sting.
Even when Sting was here,
we didn't have double stings.
-You didn't do -- not even
a double sting for Sting?
-We didn't even bring it up.
-That's weird.
I'm into tantric stings.
-You are --
How is -- How is --
How is the baby?
[ Funk music plays ]
-Yeah, there it is.
There we go.
All right.
-How's the --
-How's the baby?
-Yeah.
-I love the -- I didn't even --
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
Was I interrupting
you grooming your beard?
-I don't know
what you're talking about.
-i know.
What's your --
-Oh! Oh, this?
-"Oh, this?"
"Oh, my tiny beard comb
that I have on a chain?
[ Laughter ]
-Sometimes when I'm just
with my friends,
I just, like, ask about
the family
or something like that.
-Well, I mean -- You know.
-Like, the kids
are good and everything?
-Yeah, kids are good.
I mean, you know.
Uh, the kids are good.
You don't have time
to do things you want to do.
Oh, God.
-That feels good.
-I like the sting on this.
I love a beard-grooming sting.
-A beard-grooming sting.
-Oh, a beard-grooming sting.
Thank you.
-I had this bit all day for you.
-Oh, thank you.
I appreciate that.
-Sorry about that.
-Yeah, I have a 1 1/2-year-old.
He's a wonderful child.
-Are you loving it?
-It's so fun.
He's so --
And, like, he learns every --
For like three or four weeks,
he was going, "Bah-bay, bah-bay,
bah-bay," and we couldn't
figure out what it was
until my wife, Lily, was like,
"Oh, he eats blueberries
all day long.
"Bah-bay.
Bah-bay-ree."
[ Laughter ]
He was calling for blueberries
all day long.
-"Bah-bay, bah-bay, bah-bay."
And then --
And we just feed him.
He just -- And he looks like
Violet from "Willy Wonka."
[ Laughter ]
-That's unfortunate.
-Oh, man.
It's a medical condition.
-Medical, yeah.
I'm sorry about that.
Well, I'm happy.
I want to talk to you
about your stand-up special.
It comes out tomorrow.
And I know that your child
had a lot to do with the title,
"Little Big Boy."
-Yes. You know, I'd been touring
for a while before the lockdown,
and my tour was called
"Middle Aged Boy."
And it's sort of
stand-up about --
You know, I'm in my 40s with
a bit of a Peter Pan complex.
I still -- I got hypnotized
'cause I'm addicted to snacks.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you really?
-Yeah, like I'll walk into
my kitchen, open the pantry,
just go like, "Snack attack!"
Like, I have a --
I have a snack problem.
And I like --
and I've [bleep] my pants
numerous times as an adult.
And so, I think --
[ Laughter ]
So, there's a bit of, like, a
delayed, you know, adolescence.
But then,
the lockdown happened --
-I wouldn't say
that's middle-aged.
Oh, I see, it's the "boy" part.
-Yeah, the boy part.
-I understand.
-Middle-aged --
You know, you [bleep] your pants
every once in a while
as a guy in your 40s.
Jimmy, you know
what I'm talking about.
[ Laughter ]
You don't have toilet paper,
and so you just high-five.
[ Laughter ]
So -- Sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
-Sorry.
-We'll cut that part, guys.
-Nah, nah,
keep that one in, guys.
-So we'll, um --
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna reset, guys.
This is what we call a reset
in the biz.
Can I get a sting
for that reset, please?
-Let's take it
from the beard comb.
-Okay.
-That one worked.
-That works.
Thank you.
-All right.
And here we go.
And b-a-a--
-And here we go.
So, in the middle of the tour,
the lockdown happened,
and I was, like --
I got married, I had a child.
And so "Middle Aged Boy" didn't
feel quite appropriate anymore.
So, I -- my son, we call him
"Little Big Boy"
because he's not a baby,
but he's not yet a man.
-Yeah.
He's a little big boy.
-He's a little big boy.
And so, I decided to name
the special "Little Big Boy"
in homage to my wife and son.
-I cannot wait to see this.
It's on Netflix tomorrow.
And I just --
You're such a funny guy.
I would like
to spend hours with you.
But this is --
How long is your special?
-My special
is one hour and five minutes.
-That's enough.
-And that's enough.
[ Laughter ]
It truly is.
It's exactly --
I worked really hard,
and I'm really proud of it.
It's much more sort of
vulnerable and personal
and autobiographical
than much of the stuff
I've done to this point.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I'm kind of a -- I do
a lot of characters and stuff.
-Do you do characters
for the baby?
-I do.
I do voices for the baby.
He does not like most of them.
[ Laughter ]
But when he cries a lot,
I'll do Elmo.
He's never watched
"Sesame Street."
He has no idea who Elmo is,
but something about
the pitch of that voice...
Like, he'll be crying,
and I'll be like,
"Hey, it's okay!
What's wrong today?"
And he'll just go --
And he just goes, "Hi,"
like as if someone else
has walked into the room.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-He's like, "Aah!"
"Hey, it's all right, bud."
"What? Hi, hi."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Bah-bay, bah-bay, bah-bay."
-"Bah-bay."
In this special, I will say --
no spoilers --
but you do a great
Jason Statham impression.
-Thank you. Well, that --
I did my Jason Statham
impression on this show,
my famous --
my famous
Jason Statham impression.
-Wait, wait, wait, this show.
-Your show.
-The special comes out tomorrow,
I know.
-Yes, the special
comes out tomorrow.
-It's not famous yet.
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
-It's about to be famous.
-My classic, one of the top five
stand-up bits...
-It's not out until tomorrow.
-Everybody has seen it.
You know, everybody knows...
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
-...my Jason Statham impression.
-You did it here first?
-I did it here first
on "The Tonight Show."
You do
the "Wheel of Impressions."
-Oh, we were playing a game.
-Yes, and I had almost
no impressions.
And I thought --
I was like, "You know what?
Maybe I could do Jason Statham."
And I did it on here,
and it was really fun.
[ As Jason Statham ]
I don't know if you remember.
[ Laughter ]
-I totally remember.
It was unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-How you put in your act
made me laugh harder.
-Yeah. So, you know,
I think, like, everybody --
when --
when I look in the mirror --
Does anyone here
look in the mirror
and feel good about
what they see?
[ Laughter ]
Usually there's, like,
one guy and Lizzo, and that's --
[ Laughter ]
And that's it.
And you get it with Lizzo.
She plays the flute.
It's sexy, it's cool.
-Yeah.
-But there's usually one guy --
And, like -- So, I don't feel
good when I look in the mirror.
And the voice that I hear
when I look in the mirror is,
like, an English bully,
and he's like,
[ As Jason Statham ]
"Look at you, all red and rashy,
right out of the shower."
[ Laughter ]
"Why are you so red
when you get out of the shower?"
"'Cause I have eczema."
"Yeah, you got eczemas,
don't you?"
[ Laughter ]
So, it turned out to be
Jason Statham.
-Jason Statham
is your reflection,
and he bullies you
every morning.
-Yeah.
'Cause who's more confident
and masculine
than Jason Statham?
[ Laughter ]
And he bullies me,
and I deserve it.
-Your reflection bullies you.
-"You fat [bleep] lizard."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Why would he do that to you?
-You do Statham, don't you?
You do a little Statham?
-"Maybe I could do
a little bit."
-"A little bit."
-"I can do a little bit."
-"Yeah, it's not bad, right?"
-"It's not bad, right?
It's not bad.
It's good to see you."
-"It's good to see you."
-"Hey, Jimmy, you trying to --
you trying to grow a beard?
It's a little patchy, isn't it?"
-"Why don't you get out
your little comb
and brush your [bleep] beard?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's all in the special.
-It's all there, folks.
-Yeah, "Big Little Baby."
-"Big Little Baby"?
No, that's my rap name.
[ Laughter ]
-"Big Little Boy."
"Big Little Boy" is --
-Big Little Baby!
-BLB!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
[ Air horn blares ]
-♪ I'm a Big Little Baby,
hey ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Nick, you're always a great
guest, and you always --
You bring the goods
every single time you're here.
-I try.
-I appreciate it.
You brought us a photo.
You went on vacation.
And, unfortunately --
I'm laughing. I'm sorry.
I'm laughing
because everything's fine.
-Yes, thank you.
-You got an allergic reaction.
-Yes. I had a massive
allergic reaction.
It seems I get
an allergic reaction
every time I go on vacation.
[ Laughs ]
And I --
And then I posted this picture.
And it looks --
Yeah, you can show it.
It looks like if --
[ Laughter ]
It looks like --
it kind of looks like
if Judd Apatow [bleep]
Jeff Ross.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh...
No offense.
Those are both good-looking men,
but this is a nightmare.
[ Laughter ]
So, I posted --
I posted that, and, like --
And then I looked in the mirror
and Statham was like,
"Had to have that second mezcal,
didn't you?"
[ Laughter ]
"You're not supposed
to eat guacamole, are you?"
-"Shouldn't have gotten
that shrimp skewer."
-"Yeah, yeah!"
-"Shrimp is not great for you."
-Yeah, but then I realized,
weirdly --
I did that picture,
and then I realized, like,
if I just change
my facial expression,
that I become, like,
a different guy,
like, a guy who actually
is kind of cool.
You know, like -- who's like,
"So, yeah, it was gnarly."
[ Laughter ]
"It was pretty gnarly.
Like, I winter in Telluride,
and then I go to Costa Rica.
I'm just, like,
either I'm shredding the snow
or I'm shredding the waves."
-"Yeah, it's just gnarly."
-"It is gnarly.
And at the end of the night,
do a little mezcalito."
[ Laughter ]
-I like that.
He's, like, a gnarly, cool dude.
-Yeah, dude. Just turn
a negative into a positive.
-That's so funny.
I want to talk about
"Don't Worry Darling."
Number one, by the way.
And congratulations to you.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're the star of the film.
-I am the --
I am the star of that film.
-You got applause
in the screening I saw.
-Hey.
-Because you got a lot of fans
here at "The Tonight Show."
We all like Nick Kroll.
And we all clapped for you.
No, but this film, I will say,
obviously, we all know,
has a lot of drama behind it,
people saying all
these stories about, you know --
-Mm-hmm.
-And you told me this.
You're the mastermind
behind all of it.
-Yeah, so, the movie --
So, if you haven't seen it yet,
it's, like, a thriller.
And I think the less you know
about the movie going in,
the better
so that when you're watching it,
it's all new and surprising.
So, I decided, "Let's create
a lot of buzz around the film."
-Oh, it's genius.
-"But not about
the film itself, right?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You are a genius, a mastermind.
-You know, I'm the little --
I'm the puppeteer.
And so I was like,
"Hey, Harry, you know what
would be a great idea?
When you walk into the premiere
in Venice, spit on Chris Pine."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And he was like, "Got it."
But then, he was like, "I don't
know if that's gonna work."
So, then I was like,
"You know what?
Maybe you should just,
you know, give me a kiss."
And --
-Oww!
-Get ready, Harry fans.
-And so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I -- And then I asked him
to spit in my mouth.
[ Laughter ]
-He wouldn't do it.
-He wouldn't do that.
The guy's got boundaries.
And so, it ended up --
Anyway, but it ended up working.
-What can we say
about the movie?
'Cause I don't want
to give anything away.
I could spoil it
in one sentence.
-Yeah, I mean --
So the movie is like --
-I'm not going to do that.
-I mean, you're welcome to.
The movie is out.
It's the number-one movie
in America.
-You're gonna go for two --
let's go for two.
Let's go for two weeks in a row.
-Two weeks, baby.
-It's got good buzz.
-So the movie is like --
It feels like
a utopian community,
late '50s, early '60s.
-Everything's perfect.
-Everything's kind of perfect,
and they're working
on this project.
And -- But things
aren't exactly as they seem.
-That's the perfect way
to set it up.
You did it exactly perfect.
[ Applause ]
-Thank you.
-And wait till you see
what happens and the twist.
It's really good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Nick Kroll
in "Don't Worry Darling."
Take a look.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-Technically a worse,
less important department.
-I haven't really gotten
to talk to Frank very much.
-Frank doesn't
have to talk to you.
-Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't --
-You have no idea
how extraordinary he is
or what he can do.
You're lucky to even know
who he is,
let alone
be standing in his house.
-I'm just excited.
I'm sorry.
I was just excited.
Okay.
-Nick Kroll, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Don't Worry Darling"
is in theaters now.
And check out "Little Big Boy"
on Netflix tomorrow.
Jenna Bush Hager joins us next.
Stick around, everybody.